It's time to update your weather app,
one last time.
Here's what I want you to do.
First, add a web app manifest file and
the relevant types for
Safari and Windows.
Be sure to include all the recommended
icons and set the appropriate colors.
Next, minify and inline the CSS and
perform any other optimizations.
Finally, deploy your site to
a secure hosting provider.
When you've completed this step,
try adding your weather app to the home
screen and verify that the right
title and icons are shown.
Make sure you got the add to home
screen banner to appear on Android.
And verify that app that works when
your online, offline or in life-like.
Be sure to compare your app to
the link in the instructor notes below
to make sure that it
works exactly the same.
And don't forget to test
it in other browsers.